we're back and for this we are back and
for those of you scoring at home keep it
down honey we're doing a show here
but seriously the score is Shakespeare
for World War two two insane Italians
won its I was talking about you Roberto
you just so happy
don't do it baby don't get up
stay right there honey hello printer
person Bella Bella I live in an Italian
man that's why I know these words Bella
anyway
it's time for the visual effects award
and sometimes it gets so good - you got
to do it a second time
and - presented a man who has always had
a visual effect on me and millions of
others nominated for an Oscar for his
performance and Schindler's List his
face I have a feeling a lot of people
will be looking at on movie screens this
summer because the force is with him and
so am i honey mr. Liam Neeson
good evening in the Hollywood dictionary
there is no such word as impossible if a
writers mind can conceive anything that
can be realized by the Wizards who
produce the movies visual effects the
three films nominated by their peers for
best achievements and visual effects are
in Armageddon nominees Richard R Hoover
Pat McClung and John Fraser combined
computer graphics for a high-speed
explosion to simulate the destruction of
Paris when a fictitious asteroid hits
earth
Rick Becker Hoyt Yeatman Alan Hall and
Jim Mitchell who used millions of
digital hairs to bring a 15 foot eight
to life in mightyjoyoung
when skillfully blended with live action
the computer-generated Joe has figured
out one solution to annoying Caroline's
Joell Hynek Nicholas Brooks Stuart
Robertson and Kevin Mack conceived and
created a visual afterlife in what
dreams may come the artisans utilized
over 250,000 individual elements of
computer graphics to transform them into
an oil painting in motion
and the Oscar goes to
Jill Hynek Nicholas Brooks Robertson
Kevin Mack for Febreze Mecca
Joe Hynek previously received a
scientific and engineering award and was
nominated for his work on creditor this
is the first Oscar for Nicholas Brooks
Stuart Robertson and Kevin Mack
what dreams have come we'd like to thank
Vincent Ward for his amazing vision
Steven Simon Barnett Bane for their
faith felons summer sea juniors and Eddy
all the folks at Interscope and I'd like
to thank my colleagues and Max
Entertainment and my wife Robin and kids
in thank you for letting us make
something beautiful and cruelty free and
this one's for mass illusion to care
Jasmine Mike Schmidt Donna Langston and
to Joshua Rosen and this is my wife my
family thank you thanks to Barry my
family Mike Joyce Rocco Deakin uni Kent
Andrea Lawrence and David Ellen summers
in PLP film Nick I want to thank Scott
Ross and all the wonderful folks at
Digital Domain and my family love is
groovy be positive
ladies and gentlemen
val kilmer
his grandpa so famous they named a
street after him it's true I grew up
next to Roy Rogers ranch out in
Chatsworth California
my daddy eventually bought it so of
course I grew up fascinated with the
innocence and joy of the great matinee
movie cowboy Debbie Allen didn't
choreograph that part oh all right
he's excited come here boy sadly both
Roy and Gene Autry passed on last year
so I hope you enjoy this affectionate
tribute to the Western high ideals that
grace the silver screen for nearly a
hundred years sparked our dreams of
American adventure sugar man here let's
say Happy Trails - you ready come on
Happy Trails Happy Trails Roy